мета фірмовий знак концерті немічений
ангели меркель віку праску ромба з
читером огорнуті
де їхній ангелі меркель і за 15 руки в її
управлінню фарин можна ви справи тикають
вірусного не в мисці для України
два пази ти його ледь не готові до ангела
меркель стала can сларка вул поступалися
2005 і проти імперських 2 рядки у Юрі
дивані та україна не було топ тема в
порядку довгого фаєри англо марик лізу
стала 4 лідери в україні віктора ющенка
віктора януковича Петра Порошенка і нині
володимира зеленського зараз
президентства ющенка то януковича вгамуй
ска українських вино синок nebula жадібних
у величезних про рейдів до 2014 року
україна для німецьких політиків до
істоти за голом було по країніську
україну та депо ниють олігархи чи курям
кого не політичні еліти
євромайдан анексії крима росією
видно на донбасі
кардинально змінило ситуацію україна
вийшла тут сліпий зони ним і чини
я ангела меркель на думку гряда ніж
стала самою нею політичну фігуру і
до у панелі сіу правильному місці тов
правильна година малюків на українську не
травневу історію та для світлової
практиці я агресії Росії ж даних
документ поза виразками увага на
Петро можуть це реально силі з місця
суверенітет України
обпалять і посередника між Україною це
росію після агресії Москви на початку
2014 р. враховували раніше вітас отримано
читати їх і Великобританії ким алли бут
і найактивнішим і борються на них не пити
після
це бидо пошуки меморандумом алла самий
берлін ставок зручним портного
міжнародні експерти часто називають не
матчі але релаксант лідер так тонн хочемо
лідером для і kugou реакція на diy русі
стала вигаданою вони обоє військовим
навколо для захисту інтереси
України
скільки міжнародного права то б
стійкого до порядку в Європі та на
заслужений сум вузли волає ринку для
успішного економічного прошивання та
знайшли погано світу і негайно продовжити
надавати icecube ринку
саме завдяки особистому r kelly вдалося
а стрими їх посилено 3 зливах
вирішив рамках абсурдну коаліцію то серед
бізнес пілоти даїчі мало 3-х хто ставити
піцу мені в даті нести санте про терасу
та інші його не вплив на краї на
Європейського союзу маркель у вигляді гравано
ключову роль у за право джині продовжу
чи то посил і не санте євросоюзу проти
Росії відому сізо куди я змогла б
ти ворушиш серйозними
лбз на підлогу і пуголовок залишки не матч
він і сам сильний режим мить виглядають з
локшини і на трава ти в сіті рок і
і трекері ви вул їх би рятували дня на
росію та iso швидко володимира путіна на
цих ерколь часто критикували за і
розмелю з паном кремля загляну на
його агресивну політику рахунку України
мархелю прямому розумінню знайдуться статі
через Україну особливо 5 годин у нас
двох засуджую мінську у лютому 2015
касторка було прямо ну продовжимо 17
худим завдяки позиції меркли вдалося
вивчені ти гарячу фазу бойових де
донбасі
купа харчування залишкового укладання провини
що завищується відкритим україном і натомість
на такому позитивному для України на те
місце поза сік ангели меркель uk with не
2008-го до саркофагу прибула на саміту
нато в бухаресті
to die україні то грузії відро води ось
ріма не план вудлищ до членства в балансі
роль касторки не match in і була біля дня
з ключових
за словами учасники ВЕД їх прямо van
mark collie виступила проти подачею для
україни дослужившись до аргументу путіна
нині чим мало політики в той експерт
поважають саме блоку ваня
євроатлантичної інтеграції України
грузії розрізала русі руки для агресії
у рузі
у 2008-му зростанні та шляхи в україні у 2014
за блок живлення відіграти 17 ден з
найбільших під різних його видно сценах
ведмедик і вам і берліну
за важливої ​​речі з німецьких політики
виступати про те членства України в
альянсі
рахунковим sabbath і видно ціни в росію
крем того загині ностри по ниють і у
німецькою та suspense тві заданої мисок
заплутування німецького фонду маршала у
2014 уроки на захід вони і чиї потрібні
за пропливати українство членство в нато
57 900 кебаб це них німців сказав і не
з повною береш ерівані нас прийняти а сир
і чи джета в краї не йшла ні в альянсу
міні заданим і сос обплутування воно
замуровано центру нова європа
про прилюдне ногу наступати і 2020 уроку
за людство українці тільки в нато
виступають лише і
15 висотський вихованих німців а за
членство України і в НАТО і в ес
16900 ким спадкоємці вам сподіваюся що
petrenko членства україни в ес це нато
набагато ви зараз аритмології не нишпорить
представляти iv старшому поколінням теж
сутулість я зараз у чоловіка змініться вона
коротко його млиновий по тиг два
petrenko німецьким та поруч проекту
первинний шлях 2 нині одна з головних
на пружині
у самих вино до нього і берліна цехів
заправить мої проекти дном балтійську
море та транспорту вати газ з Росії так
не матч він і
розвинені нори що європейському ринку
таким чином росіянам агайо тіснитися ти
за особу вид транзиту газу через
україну
мер коль на фб та напайка але ще первинно
шляху до 20 економічний проект і не треба
його
поляризувати ми поважаємо ще первинний
шляхів 2 повинен бути завершений за
проект та коригувати противники
економіки
руси це європи від heaven рік на це
україна полікувати околиці балтії то
особливо США поважають що через всю
трубу
зграя наркотичного заниженого вигляду
росію вашингтон на те ж за води в
санкції, щоб не допустити відкриття
первинного потоку 2 і кіпр і буваю на
фінальної стадії будемо дитинства петренко
реформ в Україні
україни вдова не криво петрин до
німецькому видом первинну до потоку 2 а
також плямою на неї сповнена важливий
російського до логотип ар'є та кейдж Петро
i move берлін вино самі україни та ними
чен ин і не значить але краще ніжно
початку до засобів ерколь то
двосторонніх видно саму змову українцям
різким хлопець і ось з одного боку мер
кліка доповіді ніж лозу для допомоги
україні ustream його не і агресії росії
а зінчук у попа рядний до меркель x
канцлер шредер друг путіна і кен і не
проси у та на газпром
кретова не матчі на 3 знайдиш і донор
україни після з праскою у отриманих
штативом еригін
ним сен виступав і сотні мільйонів євро
в українські реформи
а також консультант український уліту
сопливе харчування до децентралізації
українці так довіряти меркель
заданим різьблених сос про це не
концертів та ринку малюються найбільшу
спинну Петро ім ку хлопець вона з
лідерами інших країв на україні українською
вугілля дачі пропускаючий зневірою includes
вигадала помел кави зі своїх crocker ще
до Росії все треба натиснути і весело
не ви правда лося здатна шляху нам з
хатинки загибелі шу важливу формувати та
свої підходи дати їх краєм такі пост
народжувала виду російську гра сирні
політики але вліво для мірки petrenko
україна стала чим із нас разок праворуч
частки показати йому славіст історій
успіху на пост заради омського простору